hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to caught on camera this is
another observation Duty style game but
this one has a lot more anomalies
apparently so we're going okay loading
survive until 6am report any anomalies a
warning will appear if you have too much
anomalies take a moment to read the
reports section bottom right on the
screen to see all the types of anomalies
that exist I don't imagine I'm gonna be
good at this in the very beginning I
imagine this uh boy
okay
so we got moved missing strange light
distorted object to extra object strange
painting Intruder and other
okay
I don't like that the curtains are
actually moving here
huh
okay let's take this down I know I'm
gonna die so it's not exactly something
that I can do I'm already too late in
terms of
checking everything properly but there's
not many rooms
that's good
oh boy
okay
I don't like the doorway on the right
over there
that's gonna be that's gonna be pain in
the ass I gotta give you better monitors
with like less glare the problem with
doing this stuff is I have to have
lights on my face but that often means
that I have lights on my monitor too so
I can't see was there always shoes
there
was that always light was that always
open
[Music]
moved
I don't know
you say anything
huh
well that's too bad
all right might have been an extra
object but I don't know might have been
nothing
okay
I don't why can't I use a a and d to all
right whatever
oh yeah well
as expected
okay
all right I gotta do my tactic
I Bob my head like a chicken for a
little bit oh
[Music]
oh
there better not be someone in that
doorway over there on the right um
[Music]
strange painting
okay
uh-huh
damn it I don't know anything
I know nothing
uh
oh
ah wait a minute wait a minute
wait distorted object that chair ain't
right I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure
okay thank you yeah I was hoping that
was gonna actually be a thing
all right good
great so I'm not crazy
oh this looks stupid this is the only
way that I've managed to be able to
actually solve these things
because you gotta force yourself to take
in the whole room
in a way
that actually makes you look in all the
places
cause otherwise your bone
can my eyes want to go to these side
doors because they creep me out and
there's definitely going to be something
standing in them
uh
not seeing anything
Bob wouldn't know what to see
in the first place
uh wait a minute bedroom strange
painting was that one on the left always
that way
that one doesn't look quite right
but then again I don't know there's a
colorful and one on the right but then
the one on the left
well damn it I guess I wasn't taking in
the whole room that's fine
oh yeah I know I know uh moved move
moved moved moved
that's not distorted that's just moved
right that would just be moved I know I
know you know calm down
thank you all right so
even though I'm bad wait
but
but it's but it's still
was there another but wait the paintings
oh
the paintings were stacked in like a row
in the kitchen but that's not how they
were
oh
the shoes the shoes moved oh my God am I
actually gonna get this on my first try
I'm telling you guys I'm telling you the
chicken Bob it works if you try it it
works
you take in all of the things
oh man that carpet something's weird
about that carpet but I can't
maybe just just in case extra I don't
know something about that carpet doesn't
gel with my chicken bobbing damn it
I don't know I'm still doing it when I'm
not looking at anything hello
[Music]
wait a minute were those both the
windows open I don't know if both of the
windows were open like that anyway
ah ah it might not have been the windows
it might have been something else
it was something else I'm gonna double
do it just in case the windows because
the windows did not go back
which rubs me weirdly damn it
at least there's punishment for that
oh anything bizarre
oh oh oh
living room now there is that that's not
right
that's not right thank you thank you
very much
okay
okay oh
okay something something's weird over
here I don't know why but that's
catching my eye but I don't think that's
what anything was
uh
oh
boy
oh no
uh something in the bedroom is
something's trip oh holy oh my God
Intruder intruder
oh oh no no no no no no no no no
how do you fix that
how do you fix that with a shotgun how
are you fixing that
what are you doing while I'm observing
this that you can fix that
that's why I've never
heard about these games are they just
are they just like figments my
imagination
things actually happen
because both are kind of concerning
there's an SCP that's like it doesn't
actually manifest physically but it
manifests through like camera
observations okay well kitchen's a real
fun place to be
okay at least these ones are relatively
normal
other than a dude leaning in the window
either there's gonna be someone on the
right there I know it God I know it why
do I know that why am I cursed with
forbidden knowledge
oh man
oh
looking at all these
something's weird in there something's
weird there I can't tell though
uh was that was there always a picture
there by the TV
I don't remember
and by I don't remember I don't know if
I noticed
ah shoot I'm gonna go ahead and go weird
painting here because
I don't really have anything else to go
by
um but something's weird
does carpet always like that
oh man I'm boning myself
I'm boning myself uh I don't know
I don't know
I never look at the floors that's a
problem
what is that
other
other oh oh kitchen the uh um thing the
faucet I don't know if that's an other I
put moved
because technically the faucet ah well I
mean technically the handle had to move
or maybe the handle didn't move I don't
know I'm just gonna go other
go go other
something weird on the window
okay whatever I don't know why that
would be another but okay
oh there's gonna be something wait a
minute
there definitely weren't two maybe
that's in the living room I don't know I
can see it from the hallway maybe I can
only see it from the hallway
oh
oh damn all right
well that's good
I mean none of this is good but it's
good enough anyway
Mana if I just guess that there's an
intruder in that hallway and it actually
I'm gonna be very upset
I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna do this but I don't like that
I'm doing it it better not say that
there actually was one
the light the light
the LA the light the light the strange
light
there's someone standing there what's
going on there I don't understand what's
happening
what do you mean
what do you mean other I don't know
other
how do you not consider that a strange
light were there always three lamps in
this room what do you mean
I moved I don't know what's that there's
is that an intruder oh no oh what that
doesn't make any sense
oh
that wasn't even it that better not be
an intruder that better not be flick
flick
what are you I don't understand what you
are oh oh my God
Intruder in the hallway dial two that
was okay
[Music]
everything's fine
oh and there's also a strange lie here
so it wasn't even in the bedroom
great
it was a twofer
all right well good to know that some
things can extend beyond the room that
I'm looking at and I can just flail
wildly
and nothingness that painting was always
just weird
is there always a plate there hmm
kitchen
probably
okay
341. I'm doing super good on my first
try of this although the night is very
long let me just do a move in the
kitchen just because that Plate's still
weirds me out
on that chair
probably them sure probably there if
it's confirmed in the other angle then
it's wait a minute
that lamp was not like that
the lamp was not oh and the carpet's
different wait
the carpet's different
so it's like a replaced object this
carpet is was not like this
I'm actually looking at the carpets now
but that carpet was not that way
damn how do I uh
what is it an extra object I don't know
the carpet's different oh oh oh God
wait a minute I ain't good
ah shoot
okay well there's a living room Intruder
um
so oh boy oh boy well you don't need to
look at me
okay that's good I probably shouldn't
look at him really long
um but I'm just so brave
I swear though this carpet is different
this carpet is actually different unless
it was already different and it's
something else I don't know it was
different unless I already fixed it
maybe I already fixed it I don't know I
don't know what's going on whatever okay
the chair was like that so that's fine I
swear that carpet was different though
I'm going to keep trying
maybe just distorted object I don't know
I do think though that I'm remembering
what it was as the anomaly version of it
because it was like gray and like
crinkled around the edges so that might
have been the anomalous version of it
and I'm just being stupid
well this is a problem because it's been
too long since the last anomaly so I'm
boned
frick
Frick and I got so far
no not like this where's the anomalies
how can I not see the anomalies
were the anomalies
where are all the anomalies what do you
mean
oh my God oh my God
oh my God
that was great great good great I'm
gonna say something in the living room's
weird because it is I don't know
something it's got to be something right
oh yeah
[Music]
oh it was something I don't know what it
was but it was something
all right cool good to know what was it
I don't know I don't know maybe there's
also an extra object I don't know
it could be my new details I don't know
I don't I don't know
uh oh there you go it was in the kitchen
both of them I oh
I don't know what changed
there was an extra object in here are
you kidding me oh in the living I oops I
accidentally said in the living room but
um
let's say in the living room there's a
moved I don't know what it would be
but okay
all right okay that's fair well I lucked
out and if my luck can last just a
little bit longer I've only got an hour
left so that's cool four chairs three
lights
this is all fine probably
this is all fine probably this is
totally refined probably
this is all good probably
that's just the curve of the lens
this is great
well interesting that's fascinating
oh boy
um
[Music]
that is probably fine that's nothing to
be concerned about
definitely what just happened there
something
something went am I crazy you did
something go weird right there on the
right
okay
um
well
it's a little bit longer
47 40 minutes
shoot I'm not bobbing my head uh
I haven't oh what do I even do about
that I'm gonna put other
uh because I don't really oh man
I don't know if someone if a ghost was
getting like railed outside the window
there and just like had their hands
propped up against the window or
something I was
a strange
to ghost bone
I don't think science is ready to answer
those questions I don't think humanity
is ready to know the truth the truth of
what ectoplasm really is I'm you know
I'm kind of upset that half of the
things that I've seen in this
I didn't see half the things I fixed in
the well bedroom I see that distorted
ouch
that ain't right
that's not right
I tell you what a lot more Intruders
than the other versions of this game
that I've played thus far
they've been caught on camera I'm almost
there oh
I'm almost here
huh
something seems brighter in the strange
light something something's brighter
over here wasn't that it wasn't that
washed out or bright like that right am
I crazy
something's weird right
was it always like that hazy
there's always this like hazy fog I
don't know
I don't know probably not probably fine
man good thing I don't get punished for
wrong guesses oh
well damn I I win all right
foreign
let's see what happens
uh oh boy that's a lot of
oh boy
who's drinking blood Cola in a hotel
at midnight what is that
what is this shouldn't I be worried
about all these cameras in a hotel isn't
that more concerning than the actual
anomalies themselves
like is this not more concerning that
there's a camera pointed right at the
bed in a hotel like that I feel like
that's the bigger anomaly here
you know
I don't know I don't know there's no way
there's no way
this one there's no way
uh there ain't no way
there is no way
there is is there gonna be intro oh man
I shouldn't have asked the questions
about ghost boning
oh I'm gonna get answers I don't want
the truth is this camera doesn't exist
on the premises it's this whole room is
in a ghostly dimension
oh man there's no way
oh there's no way oh there's no way
oh
there is no there's no way
unless they change the blood Cola
machine I'm boned
uh
I don't know
oh there's no way
oh there's just no way
I don't know
I don't think so I didn't think so maybe
maybe there was four bamboo things on
the patio I don't know missing object I
feel like there was four
but maybe not like the four sticking up
here
nope all right it's game over all right
good great good good good good great and
good
you know what good good I'm glad I'm
glad I'm not winning in this creepy
Hotel
I'm glad I'm not taking part in this
pervert operation you deserve the ghosts
you deserve the anomalies you deserve it
all
maybe there's a strange painting in here
this whole room's strange I'm just going
to report this as anomaly in general
it shouldn't be
ah of course I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know why I'm doing it
something moved here definitely
I know
I I know I'm just gonna say there's an
extra or missing I don't know that plant
probably wasn't there
something's weird about this
I'm boned how about we just say there's
a missing object
I'm boned I'm boned
I'm dead damn it oh wait strange light
on the patio that's
yeah that's that's pretty clear yeah
that's pretty obvious
um
oh good I'm
I'm back in the Gang
this is it
in It to Win It
super good
I don't know I'm gonna say moved in the
hallway
oh
I think I see a problem
burn up again no blood cola this late
all right ice room uh strange light if
that's what that could be considered
good
honestly there's probably like something
got moved in here too I don't know
could I always hear something in the
patio I don't remember being able to
hear anything
in the patio unless I was just flapping
my gums too loudly yeah of course of
course
I don't know
oh painting
strange painting
that's weird was that always like that
that might have actually been always
like that and I didn't know but I feel
like that's yeah
yeah I can't believe that that's that's
impossible
that's not possible
that's not plausible was that light
always on I don't know
patio
um
I don't know strange light again this
light is weird I don't know what's up
with that one that's a weird light
I feel like all that's red herring on
the desk there is just trying to get my
attention but I don't know where I'm
supposed to apply my attention otherwise
oh footsteps footy steps in the hallway
freaking
is that guy still there the Rapport for
Intruder before I go back
oh no
yeah that's fine
yeah that's cool all right that's great
yeah that's that's awesome
that was super cool that was good I'm
glad
not a dick move at all why do I feel
like I get farther and farther away in
this shot every time
is there always a light up here I'm
gonna say there's a strange light right
here in the ice room probably not though
I imagine there was light here
ah I still haven't reported this room
for just being weird
I probably wouldn't accept it so
whatever man that got me good um
cliche jump scare but you know it still
got me
I'm gonna say extra object in room 302
it's called a camera it shouldn't be
there
uh-huh
yeah uh camera wasn't found because it
was hidden and that's weird
it's also a crime
is that plant always there and why is
the plant moving that oh
well all right well I I that that
hotel you know
I don't like it
I don't like it so maybe I'll come back
around to it if this gives another
update where there's another one I'll
try to beat the hotel and then do the
next one because this one um way more
Intruder anomalies which I find is
always the interesting one it's not it's
it's not always interesting to see a
like a banana move keep an eye on all
the Corn Flakes or something like that
but that was pretty good I liked it
caught on camera thank you so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
please